[Music]
riley is in minnesota hi riley how are
you
oh not too bad how are you doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
okay so my question is kind of a
two-parter so i'm gonna try and keep it
as short as possible
um
when i took um personal finance my
junior year of high school my
personal finance teacher actually showed
us your classes for her class to help
prove like reinforce for point
and
in my when i was a junior i
was not very smart and i thought you
were actually quite arrogant and i
didn't take your advice but
now my grandparents recommended i
started listening to you again and now
i'm feeling really arrogant and stupid
the table's turned
well that's okay me too brother i
understand
that's exactly what i would have done in
high school i like you
if i had watched me in high school i
would have been making fun of me
[Laughter]
that's exactly what i was doing
unfortunately because now i feel like i
put myself in quite a bit of a pickle
what'd you do
um
well to start i don't this is gonna make
your jaw drop i don't use a debit card
or cash
i strictly use credit cards okay
what's your question for today let's try
it that way
my question for chat okay um
i guess like the first part would be
um with how
i use
actually else gets the
big problem is i am 20 years old
and i bought my house when i was 19
years old
on a
5 down payment
and a 30-year loan
okay and i was wondering what should
what
should i do are you having any trouble
making the payments
no that's not the problem it's just you
after watching i've been only watching
your videos again for about five days
now and you recommend
doing a 15
uh you're 15 years old so what is that
what is your income
my income um do you want that from my
main job or from all sources all sources
oh about 40 000. good for you
good for you okay
um well here's the thing what's the
interest rate on your mortgage
uh three percent fixed okay you don't
have to do anything with this mortgage
you just need to get yourself on a plan
and just you can pay extra on it without
refinancing it
and if you pay a 30 like a 15 it pays
off in 15.
so you haven't you haven't ruined your
life you're okay
okay good that was just my biggest
concern is because when i bought the
house i thought of it in more of a
mathematical
thought process i guess you could say it
because the house is a
i bought it under market value because
the
uh area i'm in the houses are roughly
150 000 to 250 000. i got it for 110
and i figured if i spread it out over
the next 30 years
with inflation that hundred and twelve
thousand
will be
two hundred and something thousand
and the house plus interest will be a
hundred and sixty thousand so i thought
the fat part with if i paid out the full
30 years i'll end up saving money
through inflation
because 30 years from now i'm going to
be paying the same amount but with money
that's technically worth less than it is
now yeah but not really and here's why
okay
the house is going to go up in value due
to inflation
whether it has a mortgage or not
these are independent equations these
equations are not interconnected
and so you don't have to have a mortgage
in order for the house to go up in value
and so what if you had it paid for and
it went up in value oh now we've got the
formula on how to be a millionaire yeah
and
to the credit card thing he he wanted to
make it clear that he uses no debit
cards and cash only credit cards there's
other pieces to this equation that
you've got to figure out obviously the
mortgage is not syncing you financially
but i am worried about your mindset when
it comes to debt and so this is
something i want you to really take a
hard look at and go what other areas am
i willing to have payments on because
right now you're willing to have the
credit card payment i don't know if
you're paying it off i don't know what
other kind of debt you may have
but i think we need to change our
mindset here because you're 20 years old
and you're good at math but you're not
great at managing money and so i want
you to get better at the second part and
then the math will help you
going forward so you're doing great
riley obviously you made a little ouchie
here but it's not sinking you and your
income is only going to go up and as it
does i want you to pay that mortgage off
i don't know why you wanted to hang
around for 30 years that made you made
it very clear like well in 30 years no i
want this thing gone in five 10 15 years
because you have a life to live and i
don't know about you but i don't want a
mortgage
when i'm 50 years old
well you're getting ready to be done
with yours yeah i'm 32 and we're paying
it off in the next four or five months
and i'm saying sayonara and i wish i was
like you riley i was really good at math
and really bad at money management and
once i realized that there is a
difference between the two it changed
everything so go through something like
financial peace university maybe now
that uh your your arrogance has gone
away maybe it'll stick this time and
you'll listen to grandma and grandpa
cause they've got a good head on their
shoulders
it's just common sense you're fine man
uh you didn't do anything that most of
us haven't done or wouldn't do
the trick is to um
learn and change because continuing to
do the same thing over and over again
expecting the different a different
result is the definition of insanity